failure is not a bad thing failure is
the mother of all success you should
seek failures no consideration of
failure you have to be able to rise from
the failure for your definition of
failure getting things wrong is as
important as getting things right their
owner is very successfully
hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about how you can defeat failure
and as always guys as you're watching
the videos if you see something that
really resonates with you please leave
it in the comments below and put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired and if you write it down it's
much more likely to stick with yourself
as well
[Music]
yeah I think failure is the highway to
success and I know that sounds like a
platitude but society or people teach us
right they say oh if you fail and feel
uncomfortable you've done something
wrong and what I try to do in all of my
books and my presentations and my tweets
and is them you cannot get to the
mountaintop without taking a few
missteps and so a business that wants to
win you have to out fail your
competition and as human beings you know
failure is not a bad thing you know ask
yourself what's the opportunity from the
failure you're in get in the game
because when you get to the last hour of
your last day it will not be the
failures you regret it'll be all the
risks you didn't take you eventually
joined Harper's Bazaar us and in 1976 it
was you were fired and I find that
extraordinary you know they were very
clear in that they thought that I would
never understand the American market I
remember I was the editor on one shoot
that was I think it was a French fashion
shows and I just decided that it would
be interesting to have dreadlocks on the
models and I think that that pushed them
further than they could they could bear
so that was that was that was it for me
but I you know I think it's always part
of life to have some knocks as well as
some successes and take risks and you
know to learn so I think it's healthy
for everyone to lose a job as well as to
gain a job I came up with a slogan and I
told it to my kids all the time I say
there's no losing only learning there's
no failure only opportunity and there's
no problems only solutions so to me what
failure is failure is the mother of all
success if it wasn't for Michael Jordan
getting cut from his ninth grade
basketball team he wouldn't became
Michael Jordan you know if it wasn't for
I've seen an article the other day where
they were talking about Oprah Winfrey
and how she got fired because she wasn't
good for television you know did you got
people like Walt Disney who
who got fired if I'm not mistaken from a
newspaper saying he had no imagination
to maintain a look at the tally seen
these are the same people that I got a
deal with Tony was worn out what's not a
hit record so what do you tell them you
tell them you know you know that that
all they can do is learn and come back
bigger better stronger because all is
gonna do is lead you in the right
direction see if you're always winning
and you don't really understand what it
is the win you gotta take those losses
you gotta take those hits there's got to
be the valleys the peach the UPS the
Downs in order for you to when it does
happen you go wow regal no this is what
it's all about and not only that it's
never about making you guys it's always
about maintaining it that's the toughest
part you should seek failures see if
you're playing it safe you're not gonna
win if you're playing it safe like that
all say you know you were topping your
little girl better to be safe than sorry
well that's a bunch of crap it's not
better be safe than sorry it's by trying
things that you figure out how far you
can go you've got to get outside the box
like it's reported Edison tried 3000
ways before he built the incandescent
light he said he didn't deal 3,000 times
he said there was 3,000 different steps
to building a light bulb well there's
different steps to get to where you're
going and I really do treat winning and
losing exactly the same I do not let it
upset me do you think that's a big part
of why you're so successful well it's
part of why I enjoy it yeah I think it
is because I try anything like if if I'm
into an idea the idea of losing never
enters my mind see I have worked with
giants I had the good fortune of working
with Sir Edmund Hillary he was the first
man to stand on top of the world and I
worked with him on three different
occasions and the only difference in ed
Hillary and Bob Proctor is in his his
size
he's gone now but he was a big man when
he struck hands with me his hand wrapped
right around mine I felt like Oh dwarf
you know and it talked into him like it
never entered his mind he wouldn't get
to the top of the mountain but he failed
in 1951 he failed in 1952
it wasn't until 1953 that he got to the
top of the mountain
no people had died for centuries trying
to do that he said I knew if I could see
it in here I could hold it out here
still a man wrote that in the book you
can see it in your head you can hold it
in your hand and that's right yet if
you're not prepared to lose you're never
gonna win because you're always playing
it safe and there's no there's no reward
in that I always had this really gross
dangerous mentality of the no
consideration of failure just never even
considering the thought of failing like
if I want something I just go until I
get it and that doesn't always work but
I think like you said every single
artist goes through that like and I
think a lot of times you think that the
great writers are the people they just
write hit after hit after hit and they
do but it's also because they get
through all the terrible songs first and
I mean I think that's kind of every
single artist story and and I mean I
love to talk when people ask what's your
best advice for you know up Co musician
alright anybody I think it's that you
have to be able to rise from the
failures is what makes a successful
person because everybody's gonna you
have mishaps so they're gonna fall down
and it's you know the people that
continuously pick themselves up that are
the ones that are gonna find their voice
make it whatever you want to call it I'm
am pretty sure there were people who you
know headed out
as I said you know artists objected some
people have an opinion they like about
it and of course they have they're
entitled to because they pay their money
for it
but um you know I never let that stop me
I've always been able to turn my head
into great and not really accept any
down moments low peaks as a failure but
yet a lesson to teach me how to be
better stronger more wise and resilient
you know I really have never gotten to
the negative stuff
I don't really absorb it as an
entrepreneur there actually is a
definition of failure and a lot of
people ask me when do you move on when
do you when do you stop what you're
doing and say maybe this isn't working
out and I like to say well first you
have to believe in if you keep believing
in what you're doing keep going but
there's one other criteria if keeping
going means you are going to do severe
physical or mental damage to yourself
and you should move on yeah and my last
company I sort of got to that point
no I it was a success for me I mean I
ultimately sold it to a large company
out of Boston called Akamai but I was at
that point where I'd gone seven years
and it was really hard times and I knew
that if I had kept going and this little
blip of success we started to see if
that was a mirage I knew I would kind of
go I would start to go crazy like for
real failure is when is maybe when at
least I feel like I failed when I didn't
put everything I had into the into a
problem so really it goes back to the
analogy I made it at the beginning is if
you don't put it all out there if you
don't put everything you got into
solving the problem then that's failure
over all that very thumbnail sketch of
very interesting and very inspiring life
what what do you think you've learnt
most I mean what what what what would
you do differently in other words do you
know I wouldn't do anything differently
because I think getting things wrong is
is we've just talked about getting
things wrong as is important as getting
things right so I wouldn't change
anything because actually I have learnt
a lot and the thing that I've learnt is
I know what I value in life I know
what's important to me I know what I
want to spend my time doing I know the
difference is that I want to make and
more important I absolutely know what I
don't want to do I'm not going to do
anybody else does I'm just gonna do what
I want to do because life's too short
and I can't live up to other people's
expectations I can only do what I could
deliver a nice life so I put that on my
wrist to remind me all times of like
trusting himself you know I mean I'm
flawless that may pop out in Jersey good
so you know things up but you can learn
from that you know there's no such thing
as absolute failure except sitting there
and not trying you know it's like that's
absolute failure but even if you fail at
something failure is not a success
training as you learn how to do it
better the next time as long as you try
again you're smarter than the average
bear some people trying to try something
you falls apart and they walk away thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I'd love to know what did you
think of the video which clip had the
biggest impact on you and why leaving
the comments below and I'm gonna join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to black pearls 87 thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word and posting that
picture on Twitter I hope you're
enjoying it and I appreciate the support
so thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon